[موسيقى]
هنا في اللد وتحديدا في ايار مايو عام
وقعت اعتداءات وحشيه شنتها جماعات من
المستوطنين الاسرائيليين على سكان المدينه
العرب ولم تنجو منهم بقيه المدن المختلطه
ايضا
[موسيقى]
انتشرت الاعتداءات في عكا
حيث
الرمله
واللد التي تحوي عددا كبيرا من السكان
العرب مما جعلها صاحبه النصيب الاكبر
والاكثر تطرفا في هذه الاعتداءات
كيف تمكن هؤلاء المستوطنون من اقتحام هذه
المدن وكيف استمروا بعدوانهم لايام
متتاليه دون ردع من يقف في كواليس تنظيم
الصفوفهم ونجاتهم من العقاب في دوله تدعي
انها الديمقراطيه الوحيده في الشرق الاوسط
قررنا البدء بتحقيقنا بالعوده الى مسرح
الجريمه مدينه اللد
توجهنا الى المحامي خالد زبار والذي شهد
هذه الاعتداءات لنفهم ما الذي حصل هناك
ولماذا
هجوم شرطي مخابراتي عسكري شباك كان موجود
[موسيقى]
بالارهاب انك انت تقوم
بتحقيق اهدافك السياسيه اللي هي بدك تغير
الميزان الديموغرافي في مدينه اللد بواسطه
العنف والارهاب والتخويف والردع والسلاح
والاعتداع الممتلكات هذا بالضبط هذا الذي
حصل في مدينه
كان لابد لنا من الوقوف عند الحدث الاول
الذي سبق اندلاع المواجهات في اللد
وتحديدا في العاشر من ايار مايو عام 2021
حيث انطلقت مظاهره خرج فيها ابناء المدينه
تزامنا مع الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه في
القدس وغزه التقينا فداء شحاده والتي شهدت
المظاهره وما تلاها وما دار في كواليس
الاحداث
ترفع علم فلسطين او بدك نادي اهدافات
وفجاه كل اللي حواليك كانهم كانت لحظه
كانه انت موجود ببقعه
بالليل اللي ما حدش متعود يشوفها او ما
حدش يشوفها بهاي الصوره عشان هي بينت يعني
عربيه فلسطينيه مسجد وتنيسه من وراك اعلام
فلسطين والمشهد ازعج يعني كان واضح جدا
انه ازعج الشرطه يعني وهي ساعتها يعني
شافتها في العدو اللي بتهجم عليه بهاي
اللحظه وبتبدا يعني كل امور يعني الطريقه
للقمع وللعنف كانت موجوده
[موسيقى]
عدنا لنبحث في تفاصيل تلك الليله
والتي شهدت اجواء حرب غير مسبوقه وصلت
فيها اعتداءات المستوطنين الى اطلاق
الرصاص الحي بشكل مباشر على الشباب العرب
قتل واحد ونجف 2 تمكنا من مقابله الناجين
والاستماع لشهادتهم
وانا راجع عن طريق المقبره لقيت الشارع
مسكر
وكانت لخها وقايمه عرب ويكانها لخه وجايه
بسمع صوت طخ بس مطخ خبط خبطت الناس كلها
بتشرد يا زلمه نزلت من السياره
ارمحت وانا رامح مطخن
[موسيقى]
لانه كان الاشي يعني زي كانك داخل حرب
يعني يا بتعيشها بتموت سكت حالي اتصلت على
العيله على الاولاد الصغار قلت لهم ولا حد
يطلع من الدور البلدي مولعه ما على حد
يطلع من الدور سكت حالي وماشي حكيت بمسك
حالي وبلف مع الشارع بعيد عنك اثنين
بوليسيه
يسمونه بطخوني هون في راسك
[موسيقى]
العمليه اثنين نجوا باعجوبه
وموسى استشهد
كتيبه مصغره ثلاث اشخاص اربع اشخاص
تقتل شافت على ظهرين
هذه هي الفرصه
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[موسيقى]
اجوا حوالي 1000
مستوطن هجموا على
موسى
من الخوف
نزل ياخذ سيارته ويروح
فاجئوا
حاملين علم اسرائيل والجهه الثانيه حاملين
الفرد
نزلوا تخطخه
الشباب اللي معاه يتصوب بايده يتصور بكتفه
لكن ابني موسى للاسف الله يرحمه ويعفي عنه
اجته وفشكه
يعني موسى استشهد
على المحل وين مطخوه استشهد
[موسيقى]
رافقنا مالك حسونه الى المكان الذي شهد
جريمه مقتل ابنه موسى
نزل من هنا
فخوه بالنسبه اجوا هم شايف
وللسياره البيضاء موسى
هذا الدوار اللي استشهد فيه الولد هذا
الدوار نستشهد فيه وهذه كلها مستوطنين
ساكنين هنا
[موسيقى]
كمان في احنا زونا المكان
معاينه
الادله اللي ضلت
بعد الحادث
[موسيقى]
حسب الدواوير المرسوم على وضعها على الاقل
في الشباب المسافه 50 متر
[موسيقى]
واحنا من الكيكه
يوم العزاء تبع الشهيد اشوف مستوطنين من
بريه البلد نزلوا بتخسخ عن ابو جم
انا خفت على واحد انطخ عنا في الديوان
يقولوا انظر حسونه فوجع قلبي
واجوا بالليل
كتبوا على مقبره حسونه
بالعبراني بقولوا
الموت للعرب الذين قتلوا الشهيد موسى
حسونه لم يتم اعتقالهم بشكل مباشر تم
اعتقالهم بعد الضغط الجماهيري بعد تقريبا
عشر ساعات
طب ليش
وتم اعتقاله فقط ل 48 ساعه اعتقالهم اربعه
هم ل 48 ساعه بعد ذلك تم الافراج عنهم
منكم
المسجد
تعال
انا اتصلت في الشرطه شرطه مدينه الهند
وقلت لهم انه
المستوطنين لليهود هجموا على المسجد
وقاعدين بطخوا علينا رصاص حي وانا بحكي مع
مع الشرطه كان في هناك اطلاق رصاص كنت
بقول للشرطيه اللي ردت علي كنت بقولها انت
سامعه هيهم بطبقوا علينا الرصاص حي اقامت
بالقاء القنابل الغاز والقنابل الصوتيه
علينا احنا الموجودين في المسجد على
الشباب اللي كانوا موجودين فوق فانت صار
عندك في نقطه ساخنه للمسجد الكبير صار في
عندك نقطه ساخنه اخرى
البيت العزاء
وانطلقت النقاط الساخنه الاخرى في كل
تقريبا احياء المدينه كل الاحياء المدينه
عقب هذه الليله الساخنه خرج العرب لحمايه
المساجد والبيوت العربيه ومواجهه
المستوطنين وفي ظل هذه التطورات الخطيره
وفقدان السيطره في الشوارع اعلنت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه فرض حظر التجول على سكان
المدينه
[موسيقى]
كل الشوارع حجار وتكسير
وموجوده وبتسمع يعني لما بتشوف حدا بتشوف
انه مجموعات يهوديه عم بتلفلف عادي ما فيش
عليها اغلاق فيعني حاله الحظر كانت على
جزء واحد بالمدينه
ومش على الجزء مش على كل الناس
وكنا نرى المجموعات اليهوديه تتجول بكل
اريحيه وهي مسلحه كانت على فكره في نفس
الفتره لا
لا
قدموا من خارج اللد من تنظيم انفسهم
والتنسيق فيما بينهم والتجمع لدخول
المدينه كان لابد لنا ان نعود لنقرا
الاحداث من الاتجاه الاخر وان نكشف كيف تم
هذا الامر باشرنا البحث في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ورغم ما سنكشفه منها لاحقا الا
انها بقيت محدوده وكثير منها تعرض للحذف
اكتشفنا انه تم الاعتماد على مجموعات
الواتساب والتليجرام المغلقه لم يكن
امامنا سوى البحث عن شخص اهتم بتتبع ورصد
هذه المجموعات والذي تمكنا مع فريقه من
التسلل اليها اوريكول الذي كشف لنا مدار
من حديث هناك ولماذا تم اختيار هذه
التطبيقات دون غيرها للتواصل
الكثير منهم كانوا مجهولين ففي تطبيق
التيليجرام في الواقع لا يمكن معرفه من
انت ومن اين اتيت معظمها كانت مجموعات
مجهوله تماما والعديد من الاشخاص لم
يكشفوا عن هوياتهم ولاننا في كل الاحوال
كنا نتابع هذه الامور بدانا نتسلل الى هذه
المجموعات وادركنا ان الامور هناك تتجاوز
حدود الطبيعي وفيها امور فظيعه وفيها
شواهد على العنف وادله على وجود الاسلحه
وادله على وجود من ينظم نفسه لاذيه اناس
ابرياء في اسرائيل رصدنا 100 مجموعه في
الواتساب والتليجرام شملت ما مجموعه 22
الف شخص مجموعات تحمل اسماء مثل الانتقام
او الانتقام في العفوله او اليهود لا
يتنازلون او اليهود لا يصمتون او الرمله
واللد في الحرب كان هناك دعوات واضحه
للعنف والمذابح والضرب
من المدونه الديمقراطيه كان الرديف الذي
عمل في تلك الفتره مع مؤسسه فكري بورتر
لرصد العنف والتحريض الالكتروني توجهنا
اليه باسئله حول التسلح وحقيقه بيع
الاسلحه عبر التليجرام
[موسيقى]
وفقا لما رصدناه في التليجرام في تلك
المجموعات يبدو ان هناك عمليات بيع وشراء
تمت حيث عرضت الاسعار لتلك الادوات
والسكاكين والهروات كانت تجار فعلا
يستغلون الوضع من اجل بيع اسلحه الدفاع عن
النفس الاسلحه التي تعتبر عموما بانها
اسلحه دفاع عن النفس لكن من الواضح انها
كانت في سياق موضوعنا ليست بالضروره دفاعا
عن النفس بمعنى الكلمه في جزء من الامر
بدا انه اعتدى
في احدى المجموعات في مدينه القدس في
الواقع نجد هذا النص المكتوب على الجميع
ان ياتي اليوم للكفاح في الساعه السابعه
والنصف في مركز تسوق اللد فاليوم ستصبح
اللد تحت سيطره اليهود انضموا لنا هذه
مجموعات سمت نفسها مجموعه واتس اب وهي
مجموعه باسم جماعه جوشدان كتبت في الساعه
التاسعه في اللد تعالوا لندافع مع وسائل
الدفاع يتبع ذلك ايموجي السكين وايموجي
حبل تعالوا ملثمين نحن لن نتصادم مع
الشرطه وانما فقط مع العرب ننتظركم في
الساعه التاسعه في اللد وهنا مكتوب بدءا
من الاسبوع القادم سنوزع على اخواننا في
القدسائل دفاع قانونيه في المرحله الاولى
سنوزع عبوات غاز فلفل وغاز مسيل للدموع
وصيغه الجمل بحرص قانوني حتى لا يتم
اعتقالهم
صوره اخرى من مجموعه الرمله واللد في
الحرب صوره فاس من يحملها لا يظهر نفسه
فقط يمسكها بيده ويسال من يجب ان يكون في
اللد وانا على ثقه من انه تلقى اجابه
وصوره اخرى لمجموعه الرمله واللدف الحرب
تظهر مطارق لقد كانوا حقا خلاقين في نوع
الاسلحه التي يقترحون احضارها مطارقه
وادوات مدببات ومفكات ومناشير من شعر
كهربائي هذا المنشور يدعو الرفاق للاقبال
على شراء مناشير كهربائيه لنقطع اعضائهم
انها فعلا دعوات مقززه وتحريضيه وهنا شخص
يعرض صوره فيها اربعه مسدسات ومخازن ذخيره
هو لا يتفاخر بنفسه وانما فقط يصور
المسدسات يوجد في مجموعه الرمله واللد ما
يكفي من الصور ولسنا مضطرين لكتابه اي شيء
من اجل ان نفهم النوايا
بتعلن انها دخلت لون خمسميه
مسلح في الباصات لحمايه الليد يعني هذا
الخبر اللي هي بتطلعه فهاي مؤسسه بتتمول
من الدوله بس لفاميليا بيجوا
الدور الاكبر يعني كل الايام
ونحكي عن نوعوت اللي هو كمان جسم المول من
الدوله والهفا
اثناء البحث وجدنا انتشارا كبيرا لهذه
المجموعات اليمينيه في المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه المنتشره خارج اللد والتي
قدمت منها ورغم الخطر المحيط بفريق العمل
تمكنا من الوصول الى مستوطنه صناعيه تدعى
الشاعر بنيامين حيث احد مقرات منظمه
اريجافيم المموله من الدوله لنكشف كواليس
ترتيب وتنسيق الدخول الى اللد
التقينا هناك باحد المستوطنين المسؤولين
في المنظمه والذي شارك بدوره في الترتيب
لذلك كله
العربي الذي يثير الشغب يجب معاقبته ويجب
الدفاع عن اليهود ان لم تفعل الشرطه ذلك
[موسيقى]
في الواقع ما حدث هو ان مواطني للتوجهوا
الينا افادوا ان الوضع هناك صعب جدا وانه
يوجد اعتداءات من عرب ضد اليهود وان
الشرطه لا تفعل شيئا ما فعلناه هو اننا
نشرنا توجيها قلنا فيه ان كل مواطن
اسرائيلي لديه سلاح مرخص والكثير في
اسرائيل لديهم مثل ذلك التصريح ومن يرغب
بالتطوع في اللد بامكانه التوجه الينا
ونحن ننظم الامور في قوائم ونوزعهم على
المناطق
تليفوني وتلقين اتصالات من كافه انحاء
البلاد من النقب ومن الشمال ومن الوسط ومن
الضفه الغربيه ايضا لكن ليس من هناك فحسب
وانما من مختلف ارجاء البلاد
تمكنا من الاطلاع على عدد من التغريدات
تداولت دعوات لقدوم المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين الى اللد
هذا المقطع المصور تم تداوله عبر تويتر
لمجموعه من المستوطنين المسلحين الذين
قدموا من مستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
راينا في الليد حالات حيث قام الناس
بتنظيم انفسهم للوصول الى اماكن محدده
خلال ساعات محدده للقيام باعمال عنف تتحدث
عن احراق المساجد اي انهم جمعوا معلومات
وكانوا يعرفون انهم ذاهبون وعرفوا مسبقا
بانهم بحاجه الى اسلحه وانهم بحاجه الى
معرفه كيف يختبئون من الشرطه اي انهم
وفروا معلومات استخباراتيه في ذلك الوقت
[موسيقى]
هؤلاء المجموعات كانوا يمتلكوا خرائط
للبيوت العربيه
هؤلاء المجموعات كانت تمتلك كانوا يمتلكوا
معلومات عن الشخصيات
اللي ساكنين في هاي البيوت العربيه
[موسيقى]
هذا بيتي وهاي الاحجار اللي برموها عليه
من شارع
الاتجاه البيت بالمحجار وازاز
والجيران بصوروا بالاساس من فوق السؤال
الذي يتبادر للاذهان فورا اين كانت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه اثناء هذه الاعتداءات ولماذا
لم تقم بمنعها طلبنا التصوير معهم للحصول
على اجابه وهو ما لم يحدث حتى اللحظه
يعني
اليهود هاي شرطه هاي شرطه المشوار يقول
حرس الحدود
يعني بيعتدوا على العرب
قدام الشرطه موجودين باليوم الاول اتصلنا
بشكل عادي كانه تتصل على الشرطه باليوم
الثاني قررت انه بطل
يعني بمدير محطه الشرطه لاني بالبلديه
ومعي الرقم وبرضو بياخد 45 دقيقه ولما
بيجي بكونش نادي عليهم احنا العالم لما
كانوا يجوا بدهم يبعدوك عن محل يرموا على
طول قنابل صوت هون كانوا ينادوا عليهم
خبره يعني تزوزوا من هبايه هيك انه حتى
انا وقت علقت عليها يعني
ناس عم تهجم علينا
فبتفهم اللغات في حوار بيناتهم انه الشرطه
على الاغلب بتحميهم هلا احنا جوا بيوتنا
بعدين لما بتشوف الفيديوهات بتفهم انه 90%
من الحالات في حدا عم بضرب حجار او عم
بخبط وفي مقاس او شرطه عاديه حسب
واقفه وراها
[موسيقى]
تسجيل صوتي جديد تمكننا من الحصول عليه
يؤكد لنا موقف الشرطه من المستوطنين في
الميدان
[موسيقى]
لنفهم موقف الشرطه الاسرائيليه وما فعلوه
على الارض عدنا لنتتبع موقف وزير الامن
الداخلي الاسرائيلي انذاك امير اوحانه
[موسيقى]
وهذا التصريح لوزير الامن الداخلي المسؤول
عن الشوربه فيعني ان الشرطه ما اخذتش اي
اوامر بتقول انه هي تمنعهم يعني
الشرع انا جاي من فوق من الوزير من
الحكومه
في هذه الفتره وجدنا تغريدات للسياسيين
اسرائيليين تكاتفوا لاخراج المتهمين بمقتل
حسونه فورا واعتبار ما قاموا به مجرد دفاع
عن النفس
اعضاء كنيسه مختلفين يعني نبدا بس
بكمل يعني اللي بصيروا يطلعوا تصريحات انه
مش لازم يتم اعتقالهم هدول دافعوا عن
نفسهم
ولازم نتركهم
[موسيقى]
وبتصير مظاهره على باب المحكمه
اليوم يعني بالوقت اللي لسه جثه موسى مش
طالعه من المستشفى صار في مظاهره اللي
رئيس البلديه بوقف فيها
رئيس بلديه لمدينه مختلطه فهنا الضغط
السياسي بفكر لعب دور يعني
[موسيقى]
تمكنا من الوصول لوثيقه من قاضي المحكمه
يرفض فيها طلب الالتماس الذي قدمه محامي
المتهمين الاربعه بمقتل موسى حسونه من اجل
الافراج عنهم بعدها بيومين تم الافراج عن
المتهمين بضغط سياسي وفي مخالفه صريحه
لقرار المحكمه
[موسيقى]
ضمن سعينا للحصول على ملف التحقيق
والاطلاع على حيثياته
قررنا التوجه الى حيفا وتحديدا الى مقر
مركز عداله
التقينا هناك بالمحامي ربيع اخباريه
المسؤول عن القضيه والذي قدم بدوره طلبا
للشرطه الاسرائيليه للاطلاع على الملف
ما اعطتنا كافه المواد الموجوده عندها
واحنا في اجراءات للمطالبه بهذه المواد
واخذ صوره اوضح ولكن مثل حالات قتل كثيره
ممكن يكون في شخص واحد اللي تم اطلق النار
ولكن بتشجيع من من اطراف اخر ومن اشخاص
اخرين وبمساعده اشخاص اخرين فهناك يعني
اطراف متعدده
لاي قضيه
[موسيقى]
ومن هاي اللحظه بصير مانع نشر على اي اشي
بخص هاي القضيه لحد انتهائها
في ظل هذا التعتيم الاعلامي الكبير
والتكتم الشديد على ملف التحقيق ومسح اي
بيانات تتعلق بقتله حسونه ومنع النشر تحت
طائله المسائله القانونيه توجهنا للمحامي
الاسرائيلي الذي قدم طلب الالتماس للافراج
عن المتهمين والذي تولى الدفاع عنهم عيدي
كده الذي رفض بدوره الادلاء لنا باي تصريح
[موسيقى]
منع حتى المحامون الناشطون الذين تولوا
الدفاع عن الاشخاص الاخرين المعتدى عليهم
في واقعه مقتل حسون من الاطلاع على
التحقيق ومعرفه المتهمين ومنهم تيسير
شعبان محامي الشاب عيسى شعبان الذي لم
يتمكن من الحصول على نسخه من التحقيق ولا
حتى الدخول الى قاعات المحكمه
مش فقط نشر
الاسماء كمان منع المحامين يدخلوا على على
القاعات التعرف على الشخصيات الموجوده او
تعرف على القضيه نفسها هل عنجد في معتقلين
احنا نحكي على سلاح ملخص بنحكي على فاشك
او رصاص اللي هو مسجل يعني عمليا سهل جدا
من خلال ثواني تعرف مين القاتل وبعدين شو
هو بيعترف اصلا لكن هو بدي عينه دفاع عن
النفس هو اللي هاجم عن ابني
من بعد بتقول لي دفاع عن النفس قالوا دفاع
عن النفس شفتوا معاه باروده فرض كلاشنكوف
ولا شيء وهلا بالفيديو هذا طلع الفيديوهات
هذا اللي هم صوروا عرض 12 بيجيبوها
هاي حامل العلم وحامل الفرد هو نفس البني
ادم اللي طلع بالسياره هديك
وين الدفاع عن النفس اللي بيحكوا عنه
ابعث لي اياها
في واحد ورا واحد
هذول هم هدول الدتيم هم بيجوا تحت
العمارات كانوا يقوموا حالهم وبعدين
يهجموا على دور العرب يعلمه يكونوا معلمين
هم مش من اللي طبعا هدول بيجوا من برا
اللد بيجيبوهم بحطوهم وين نحكي بحطهم تحت
عماره بكونوا حالهم بيجي واحد اللي معلم
الدور بدلهم على دور العرب عشان يتهجموا
عليهم
محالهم بحضروا حالهم هدول الكمرات اللي
صوروهم تحت الدور كيف بلتموا كيف بحضروا
حالهم بالفيديوهات مبين سلاحهم على جنبهم
كيف هم جاهزين وهذول مش من
واحد فيهم اذا كمان لابس شنطه هذا حامل ام
16 هاي ناس مش جايه تدافع عن نفسها ناس
جايه تقتل
بعد مغادرتنا قامت الشرطه باعتقال ايوب
حسونه
[موسيقى]
تتبعنا في التحقيق اهم الوجوه التي نشطت
خلال فتره الاعتداءات وكيف شكلت غطاء
ودعما للمستوطنين بدانا بعمي خايلاند فيلد
عضو بلديه اللد رفض عميخائي التحدث الينا
بشده
انا خلاص
واضحه
في اثبات جديد فيما لا يدعم مجانا للشك في
معرفه الشرطه واعضاء البلديه المسبق بحضور
المستوطنين المسلحين الى اللد رصدنا جلسه
طوارئ للبلديه عقدت بحضور اعضاء من
الكنيست تم التداول فيها بشان حافلات تنقل
المستوطنين المسلحين الى داخل المدينه
بقول جايين بالطريق باصات
اللي جاي من المستوطنات وجاي من يلم وبعد
مستوطنتين او ثلاثه
وبنصح العربي يدخلوا الابواب ويتخبوا يعني
اتصلنا بالشرطه نقدم شكوى انه جايين بساط
والشرطه قالت انه مش قادره اوقفهم وكان
قبلها باربعه وعشرين ساعه انبسط طالعه على
الاقصى من 48
وكلها توقف
وانا اجي لك يا مشوه
بوسي فلسطيني
المسؤول عن جمعيه الاهافا في تنظيم وتخطيط
وتنسيق يكشف عن عمل المنظم وليس مجرد
افراد يرغبون بالاعتداء
وكان لمنظمه لهافا واتباعها مثل جوبشتاين
غايه قويه جدا في خضم احداث العنف تلك فهم
من صب الزيت على النار وقام بالتحريض حتى
ان مفاوض عام الشرطه الاسرائيليه قال ان
اتمار بنكفير هو الذي بدا هذه الانتفاضه
الى المظاهره في المدينه انشئت مجموعه
كبيرتان ضمت العديد من الاعضاء
مؤيدتان له وتدعمان الاراء التي ينادي بها
نشرت مئات الاف المنشورات لم نستعرضها
كلها لكن
على مدى اسبوع واحد او عدد من الايام كان
حجم التحريض ملحوظا جدا
بينما لعب اوحانا
وغيرهم من السياسيين دور التحريض والتبرير
للاعتداءات كان على الارض من نفذ ذلك
بيديه وصلنا لواحد منهم المستوطن
[موسيقى]
عملاق
وكما توقعنا رفض بشده التحدث الينا
[موسيقى]
هذه التغريده قادتنا لمستوطن المتطرف تصدر
لقياده الاعتداءات يدعى
تبين انه جندي سابق في الجيش الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
فيما بدا انه اتفاق بينهم شرشان ايضا رفضت
التحدث الينا
كانت
بلديه اللد كانت الحاضره الغائبه في هذه
الاحداث حاضره بشخص رئيسها ونائبه وغائبه
بدورها في منع وقوع الاعتداءات بل
تجاوزتها بتقديم دعم اللوجستين للمستوطنين
الذين قدموا من خارج اللد وهذا ما سعينا
للتثبت منه
هذا المبنى البلديه من جوا
وهاي المشهد بدكم
هدول الاجمل هذا ما بدنا البلديه قاعدين
جوه هم فتخيل مع خرايط لابتوبات
[موسيقى]
مدير عام البلديه اللي هو اقامه
واضح انه كان مجند للعمليه بمليون بالمئه
لانه مش راح ياخدوا مفتاح مبنى بلديه بدون
اذنه
عدنا لنعرف كيف تم تعيين ارون مديرا عاما
للبلديه من قبل رئيسها في عام 2013 فتبين
ان كليهما داعم ومؤسس للانويه التوراتيه
والاستيطان في اللد وكانت تعيينه حينها
بمثابه اعلان حرب شامله على العرب هناك
حيث قام مواطنون برفع قضيه ضد تعيينه بسبب
تاريخه المعادي للعرب ولمواقفه العنصريه
المعلنه كما جاء في الشكوى
[موسيقى]
الا ان المحكمه ردت القضيه ثم تكرر ذلك
على خلفيه احداث الليد وذلك بالمطالبه
باقاله
[موسيقى]
كانت هذه المره الاخيره التي يجيبنا فيها
يائري فيفو هاتفيا ولم يلتزم باي موعد بل
استمر في المماطله
[موسيقى]
ارسل لك فريق تصوير غدا في مكتبك الساعه
11 صباحا يصور معك المقابله
والعمل
التنسيق يعني
التمسك لتسويق ما تقدر ترد على بعض
الاسئله الان
انا
تمام بكره اكلمك
متى واضحا لنا وجود اجماع رسميا اسرائيلي
على عدم الظهور في هذا الفيلم
[موسيقى]
جوهر
الموضوع الذي يدير البلديه
ويدير رئيس البلديه هو ارون اتيس هو
النواه التوراتيه لنفهم اكثر عدنا لبناء
الانويه التوراتيه كمصطلح على تسميتها
اسرائيليا وهي المشاريع الاستيطانيه
الزاحفه في المدن والبلدات داخل اسرائيل
ويتمثل هدفها في محاصره الفلسطينيين سكان
البلاد الاصليين والتضييق عليهم وصولا الى
طردهم نهائيا من المدن المختلطه
كالرمله
وعكه ولد والتي سميت كذلك منذ احتلالها
عام
1948 حيث هجر اهلها وتبقى فيها جزء من
السكان العرب اجبروا على العيش داخل احياء
المحاصره ما حول سكان الاصليين الى اقليه
مهمشه فيما سكن المهاجرون الاسرائيليون في
بيوت العرب المهجرين ومنذ ذلك الوقت ظل
التوسع الاستيطاني الشغل الشاغل للحكومات
الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه ورصدت له ميزانيات
ضخمه والهدف حسم هويه المدن المختلطه مدنا
يهوديه القوميه بزرع عائلات المستوطنين
هناك
[موسيقى]
لما
هاي حاره اسمها اللي هي بنت اول حارم بنات
وكانت بسبسود بناء ميزانيه الدوله والمبنى
بالضبط الملزق فيها هو
قسم الامن تبع البلديه هم ملزقين ببعض
يعني هذا كمان بيحكي على نوع من العلاقه
الموجوده
وبين
وبين البلديه جزء من عمليه بناء البلديه
هي السيطره على الحيه
وتهويده يعني جعله اكثر
يبين يهودي
مش ابدا مش بالصدفه محلها كان دكاكين او
محلات قديمه محل البلديه كله محلات تجاريه
عربيه
هون بعد وفاه المخابرات على الليدو بلش
بعد بطل اسلحه
يعني
[موسيقى]
العرب قبل ان يتعرضوا للاعتقال ايضا فهل
كان ينقص الشباك توقع الاحداث وارهاصات
الجرائم التي حصلت وخرجت عن السيطره حتى
تؤخر دخولها كل هذا الوقت
تمكنا من مقابله الرئيس الاسبق لشعبه
السايبر في المخابرات الاسرائيليه الشابك
توجهنا اليه بسؤال كيف تمكن المستوطنون
المسلحون من الدخول وكيف حصلوا على
الخرائط
انا لا اصدق انه تم اعطائهم خرائط من اجل
تحديد البيوت العربيه كي تتم مهاجمتها هذه
النقطه الاولى اليهود المسلحون مثل ما قلت
ان جاءوا مسلحين ومعهم تصريح ويحق لهم
التجول لكن مع حمايه انفسهم اكرر مره اخرى
لا يجب ان يكون هناك مسلحون في المناطق
المستتبه وفي الاماكن المتوتره يفترض ان
يكون فيها الشرطه ويفترض بالشرطه ان تساعد
في فرض النظام العام لكن ان كان هناك مسلح
ولديه رخصه فيحق له التنقل والتجول
[موسيقى]
كل وجوه بين قانونيه ممكن اعتقال لهم
جميعا ويدخالهم السجن جميعا ما فيش ولا
معتقل وظيفه الدوله هي منع اعمال العنف
قبل وقوعها لكن تلك المجموعات لم يتم
رصدها وتحيدها من قبل الشرطه ولا من قبل
اي جهه اخرى في دوله اسرائيل الى ان
ابلغنا نحن في الفكر بورتر الدوله ان ذلك
يحدث
والشباك بدوره لديه قسم يختص باليهود لكن
معظم طاقاتهم وظيفه نحو الفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
هل حقا كانت قدرات الشباب عاجزه عن رؤيه
ما تمكنت مؤسسه مجتمع مدني من معرفته
[موسيقى]
اعطيك اجابه مهنيه بدون ان اكشف عن
القدرات يوجد قدرات متطوره جدا ويجب القول
ان عالم السايبر والتكنولوجيا يوفر في
ايامنا الكثير من الامور لم نكن نراها قبل
احدى وعشرين سنه وساكتفي بهذا القدر
الاكسب شيك الواحد من كل ذلك
لنبدا بتحقيق مرابح فانا لست مستعدا
لاجراء مقابلات ضد اسرائيل مجانا
على وقع هذه الاحداث ومنذ ايار مايو اطلقت
الشرطه والشباك حمله اعتقالات غير مسبوقه
طالت العربه في جميع المدن المختلطه
بالمقابل لم يتمكن الجهاز الشروطي
والقضائي من الابقاء على اعتقال قتله
حسونه او ادانتهم حتى اللحظه
توجهنا الى غاز شعبان والذي تعرض لاعتقال
وحشي من الشرطه الاسرائيليه
واحد من افراد الشرطه صار يرفع ايده عليه
واخذوني معهم
لما وصلت هنا كان واحد ماسكني هيك واحد
ماسكني هيك وانا هيك واحد مسكني هيك واحد
مسكني هيك وضل مجربين في لحديت الحاويه
هذيك هم ماسكني عند السياره هذيك مسكونه
كمان بلشوا تضربوا في غد في تبعتهم
ودخشوني على السياره وبلشوا يضربوا
من ايار الاخير شاهدنا الاف الاعتقالات
اكثر من حال الفين حاله اعتقال
لاشخاص فلسطينيين بغالبيه الحالات لم يتم
تقديم لائحه اتهام اساسا
لم تقدم الشرطه اي اعداد رسميه للمعتقلين
لكننا تمكنا من الحصول على رد من وزير
القضاء يتضمن اعداد من تم تقديم لائحه
ادعاء بحقهم فقط وليس كل من تم اعتقاله
ووفقا لهذا الرد
[موسيقى]
يعني هلا احنا بعمليه توثيق هيك اللي
بنرقد فيها
اللي يكون عنا كل اشي مسجل وكل هذا بس
الناس كمان كانت تخاف ما تروحش على الشرطه
تقدم بلاغات تروح تتعالج بالضفه مرات عشان
ما توصلش هون المستشفى لانه حاسس انه كل
شيء ضدها
يعني انا مش عامل اشي جيفني واقف ليش تخبط
طب اذا انت المفروض انك تحميني مثلا عن
الشباب اللي بطخوا هدولاك او انه اللي
بضربوا حجار انت تيجي تضربني انا طب ما
انا يعني بعيد عنك 4 متر يعني رسمه الهاب
اثنين انت يعني انا واحد ويا دوب يعني
يعني تقدر تيجي تمسكوني اذا انا عامل اشي
بس انا مش عامل اشي
طخيتني
اما عيسى فاكتفت الشرطه الاسرائيليه
بالتحقيق معه وكانه في موقع اتهام عوضا عن
القاء القبض على الجاني
وين كنت وين رحت وين جيت هم عرفوه وطلعوه
يعني عادي
مبين في فيديو كليب
هذا انه طخ وفيه كل شيء
وروحت
لكن ليس امام الكاميرا بدون تسجيل لا
اوافق على تسجيل ما ساقوله
في نهايه المطاف الا يحق للمواطنين العرب
الحصول على الحمايه الدوليه واجراء تحقيق
دولي في الجرائم التي ارتكبتها اسرائيل
بحقهم وتسترها على الجنات واحتضانهم في
الوقت الذي ما زالت تسعى فيه لكتم كل صوت
يحاول اظهار الحقيقه بالتهديد المباشر
على الفيسبوك يعني بعد ساعتين من البوست
رجعني اسطوره البوست منه برساله من رئيس
البلديه وتحتها انه
انه راح امرق اسمك للشباب
عشان يعني
يضل يلاحق وراكي ويخرب حياتك بقدرش يقول
لي انت برا البلديه لانه انا داخله باصوات
الناس مش يعني مش موظفه عنده
[موسيقى]
لو انه رئيس البلديه يقيير لفيفو مع
مع اوخانه مع رئيس الحكومه
بقاش اتفاق انه يدخلوا هدول المتدينين ما
صارش اللي صار بقلب اللد
[موسيقى]